so it is CES 2019 and the first thing
that we're checking out today we're in
the Samsung booth and we'll be checking
out their new Q LED TV they've got an
aka television they announced ninety
eight inch television and it is so
amazing they also announced a 75 inch
micro LED television which is modular so
basically you can customize this thing
to be any size any ratio and so far it
is one of my highlights
isn't gonna fit your face that's okay
there's other options and
these not fitting in your space 375 inch
micro LED tube you see
it's modular so you can basically make
it any size to any ratio up scale you
don't have to worry about screen
resolution
be whatever you want it to be we need to
go find those
right now we are here at the Samsung
first looks event I've actually never
been to one of these you are some super
excited I know they have some really fun
things for us to check out so that being
said let's go check it out
[Music]
one of the highlights obviously was the
new 75 inch micro LED TV that they
announced and the wall was a huge hit
last year as yes but now it is even
bigger and better because you basically
can figure this thing to any size that
you want you're contacting basically
scale so
that cave whatever ku1 you can do that
with the micro LED modular system they
have in place so behind me is a really
good example of how this modular system
works so they kind of have these moving
panels that just connect back and forth
and they just seamlessly integrate into
whatever it is that you're watching so
they said that the ratio size doesn't
matter like these
side to side there's also a guy over
here doing a demo showing you how easy
it is to get the morning
[Music]
this is the wall this is so amazing
because you can really honestly be
whatever you want it to be any size and
ratio anything like it can be like this
big or it can be this big
[Music]
Hey supersnap hate us I'm just hanging
around neither wall do you think that we
can do you think we can fit this in our
bag I think we should try okay try we
can probably get it through customs well
I don't have to go through customs Oh in
my house yeah we just keep it at your
eyes just cover one wall what do you
think like is this the future like
modular televisions my micro LED does
look a bit yeah I mean if you look at
the quality of it the colors the viewing
angles it's pretty sick
I mean you can actually be anywhere and
it still looks incredible and he could
be 21 by 9 you can be 16 by 9 I love it
so much
oh my goodness okay let's go see some
more things
just kidding gonna say I'm gonna do
let's just stay right here this is
actually crazy this is better than any
roller coaster I've ever been on
I think this is I think I need a folder
for my Instagram here is showing you how
ai and upscale content so content that
is not ready for a television we're able
to use that ai and take anything shot in
for example I'm Jun is 4k
we're able to use AI and upscale that to
a K so the fantastic
don't shoot it and this kind of gives me
do you have an 8k television obviously
the stuff that I'm shooting is not yet a
K but the spork' content will be
upscaled and it will still look amazing
so this is the quantum processor 8k and
this is what basically makes everything
happen rai upscaling ai streaming
technology rai content and connectivity
and our ai sound what
they are making the television
with family health especially they want
it to be a place that you can go to
connect watch TV now you can make that
TV be as subtle or is not subtle edge
one this is the frame it's art right
here because like
TV what it's on heart when it
that's an actual baby
I just got trades
okay I can't even tell what's my order
[Music]
a huge announcement that happened here
at CES if Apple and Samsung are now
partnering together so you will be able
to watch iTunes movies and TV shows on
your Samsung Smart TV and that's not it
you'll also be able to use airplay too
so you can send things from your iOS or
your Mac OS devices to your Smart TV and
this is a kind of crazy I know I was
just as shocked as you are when I heard
that announcement but I am so excited
about it
if you let a case the 98 inch version
and this day is size comparison over my
body
[Music]
look who I just ran into CES 2019 bud
I've been reading you years so how many
see us to be bit too so this is nice
my 13 was 2011 so you might have the
wall is so it's Moodle wall it really is
I just rated this app and we were trying
to figure out how we can take it off of
this wall and put it on our walls
I would bill I would go into debt to
build a house to fit the wall like you
know it's worth it it's incredible but
it could be any size so you know you can
make it has to be that size does it's
got to be like that
and giant and I want to play games on it
and love it and I want to sleep next to
it and I want to name it Fred can you
imagine gaming on Fred so cool I would
probably have less reason to leave the
house than I do now that's true I never
I would never want to leave so the
marriage of television and AI is
something that is so fascinating to me
because a lot of the future is moving
towards AI tech and there's another
thing called universal guides so based
on your current subscriptions that you
have they'll be able to determine what
you might want to watch I'm so excited
about the future and it's crazy because
the future is actually here now
so thank you guys so much for checking
out this video I look forward to showing
you some more things that I see it CES
let me know if there's anything else
that you'd like me to check out while
I'm here and a huge thank you to Sam
site for partnering with me on this
video because I absolutely have loved
everything that I've seen and I cannot
wait to get my hands on one of these
wink wait am i winking I'm not am i
winking
I think I'm weak a trying I'm trying
alright I'll see you later
[Music]